Merci merci beaucoup, c'est un voyage un peu
vertigineux vous nous avez fait faire là
On est parti là haut du côté des
exoplanètes que l'on imagine qui nous
font rêver puis on est retombé assez brutalement
sur Terre
Le message est clair je pense et il y
aura peut-être des réactions par rapport
à ce message dans la salle il y en a..
y à quelques questions aussi sur le site
internet : "a t-on réussi, entre autre, à
prendre une image réelle d'une
exoplanète"
Alors oui, comme celle que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure au tour de
HR 8799 qui tourne autour de son
étoile, c'est à dire un petit point qui bouge
On a pas mieux
et les images que vous avez pu voir dans
des médias ou quoi comme celle qui a
servi pour illustrer cette conférence ne
sont que des vues d'artiste on est
encore pas capable de faire une image
d'une exoplanète comme celle là même avec
le télescope le plus puissant du monde
et on n'en sera pas capable avant très
très très longtemps parce que c'est
juste impossible tout ce qu'on voit
c'est un petit truc qui brille autour
d'une étoile et c'est déjà hyper dur
d'isoler ce petit point dans le flot de
lumière de l'étoile
ça revient être capable de voir une
luciole qui serait poser sur un phare de
marine donc c'est déjà un
exploit technique et de voir ces petits
points c'est voilà ce qu'on a comme
vision d'exoplanètes on en connaît
plusieurs mais ces quelques petits
points c'est tout.
alors les questions
dans la salle si vous en avez courtes
et vous parler fort et vous vous levez
merci allez-y
On parle de zones d'habitabilité, autour de certaines étoiles.
L'eau serait à l'état liquide, dans cette zone là
et a t-on l'espoir de trouver des traces
d'oxygénation, de vivant, etc.
C'est une excellente question, je vais peut être la répéter au micro pour que tout le monde
entende on parle de la zone
d'habitabilité pour autour des étoiles
c'est la zone qui n'est ni trop près ni
trop loin de son étoile
de telle sorte que il fait ni trop chaud
ni trop froid et donc si on met de l'eau
à la surface
elle va ni s'évaporer ni gelés on peut
avoir de l'eau liquide
cette zone d'habitabilité la Terre est
dedans, Venus est dedans aussi, Mars est
dedans également mais ni Venus ni Mars
ne sont habitables donc c'est pas parce
qu'une planète et dans la zone habitable
qu'elle est habitable
par contre elle peut l'être on connaît
déjà plusieurs planètes qui sont dans la
zone habitable et donc la question qui
se pose c'est effectivement est-ce qu'on
peut s'intéresser à ces planètes et
essayer de détecter des traces de, on
appelle ça des biosignatures c'est à
dire des phénomènes qui serait causée
par la vie on y travaille
il y a des projets de missions spatiales
avec des télescopes dédiés à ça on pourra
on espère bientôt on a le E-ELT, le
extremely large telescope qui va être
construit au Chili qui fera 39 mètres de
diamètre qui a pour but de collecter un
maximum de lumière des étoiles autour
desquelles, il y à des exoplanètes et quand
la planète passe devant l'étoile il y a
une petite partie de la lumière de
l'étoile qui est filtrée par
l'atmosphère de cette planète et donc si
on analyse finement ça on peut avoir une
idée du spectre de cette atmosphère
selon les molécules qu'il y à dans
l'atmosphère, certaine longueur d'onde de
lumières vont passées ou être bloquées et
donc en analysant ça on espère détecter
des biosignatures, mais c'est extrêmement
complexe parce que toutes les molécules
ne sont pas forcément créée que par des
phénomènes biologiques ou que par les
phénomènes minéraux et on ignore tout de
la chimie et des exoplanètes jusqu'à
présent mais c'est la direction dans
laquelle s'oriente la recherche en
exoplanètes ce n'est plus maintenant de
les détecter et d'en trouver le plus
grand nombre mais c'est d'en trouver
quelques unes pour lesquels on peut les
caractériser et idéalement analyser
leurs atmosphères et espérer découvrir
un jour la vie
une autre question ? Oui, allez-y je vous en prie
Vous avez dit qu'il n'y avait aucune forme de vie qui avait réussi à conquérir la Voie Lactée
à cause de ces problèmes de croissance
Est-ce que vous pensez que progrès
technologie va avec croissance ? C'est à
dire que si on réussi à ne plus rester dans ce modèle
de croissance, qu'on réussit à changer de modèles, est-ce qu'on réussira quand même à avoir un progrès
technologique suffisant et qu'on pourrait imaginer "conquérir" la Voie Lactée ou en tout cas découvrir
la Voie Lactée, non pas dans 100 ans mais dans 500, 1000 ans, sans avoir ce modèle de croissance ?
C'est une bonne question
j'ai peur de pas avoir la réponse exacte à
cette question mais voilà on peut on
peut y réfléchir c'est à dire l'idée
serait de ne pas avoir cette croissance
de notre consommation d'énergie et de
notre extraction de ressource dont on
sait qu'elle n'est pas durable mais
avoir quand même du progrès
technologique de sorte qu'un jour on
arrive à aller vers les étoiles
je pense que oui il est possible
d'avoir un modèle économique dans lequel
on a du progrès technologique sans
croissance
un truc tout simple je sais pas si c'est
viable économiquement mais en tant que
mathématicien pour moi ça marche ou
physicien
on a besoin de croissance actuellement
parce que la rentabilité augmente donc
grâce aux progrès techniques et donc à
heures de travail fixe et on produit
plus donc si on produit pas plus bas il
faut mettre des gens au chômage
on pourrait imaginer que quand les
progrès
en rentabilité on diminue le temps de
travail en produisant toujours la même
chose, historiquement, ça c'est un peu fait
mais pas dans les proportions énormes
donc on pourrait avoir toujours du
progrès technologique et simplement on
n'exploite pas plus les ressources et
du coup on aurait besoin de moins
travailler etc
quand je dis qu'il faut arrêter avec la
croissance je dis pas qu'il faut revenir
à la lampe à huile
je dis que l'on garde tout ce qu'on a le
super les progrès dans la médecine les
progrès dans l'hygiène les progrès il ya
des tas de progrès technologiques qui
sont extraordinaires la machine à laver
le lave-vaisselle, rien que ça par exemple on va
les garder par contre il faut réfléchir
à notre consommation d'énergie
regardez que on a droit a en moyenne je
crois que ces deux tomes par personne de
co2 émis par an c'est le maximum on est
à 5 en ce moment en france
ben voilà vous avez deux tonnes par an
choisissez votre budget si ce que vous
préférez savoir une grosse voiture
mais faire la lessive à la main vous
avez le droit si vous vous dites tant
pis je prendrai le vélo mais je prends
un sèche linge, vous avez le droit
donc on peut comme ça avoir toujours des
progrès technologiques sans augmenter notre consommation d'énergie
de là à aller jusque dans les étoiles ça
va être très difficile parce que là il
faut de l'énergie. Vous pouvez pas lutter
contre l'énergie potentielle de gravité
il faut accélérer les vaisseaux et ça ça
demande beaucoup d'énergie
donc là je suis moins optimiste
la théorie des grands filtre est elle la
réponse à Fermi ?
La théorie des grands filtre dit que dans notre
progression depuis les premières
bactéries qui se sont formés à la surface
de la Terre jusqu'à nous, excusez moi on
a dû passer par plusieurs filtres qui
aurait pu, ou tout aurait pu s'arrêter
Le premier filtre c'est évidemment
l'apparition de la première forme de vie
alors qu'on avait une chimie prébiotique
qui aurait pu très bien rester à l'état
de chimie et pas passer à l'étape du
vivant le deuxième c'est de passer de la
vie unicellulaires à la vie
pluricellulaire et puis il y en a à
chaque nouvelle étape technologique
la question c'est de savoir si avant on
peut effectivement résoudre le problème
de faire le paradoxe de Fermi en disant
qu'il ya aussi des filtres dont un qui est quasiment impossible de passer
La question c'est est-ce que ce filtre
est derrière nous et on a eu la chance,
on a gagné au loto dans la loterie
cosmique et on a réussi à passer ce filtre
et donc on est les seuls. Où est ce qu'il
est devant nous et on risque de pas le passer
alors je ne sais pas s'il ya un filtre
dernière nous qu'on a réussi à passer
par contre je sais que mathématiquement
le développement de l'exponentiel,
c'est un filtre qui est devant nous
Question dans la salle ? Non ? Alors j'en
pose une autre ici sur internet. Que
pensez-vous du traitement médiatique de
la détection de phosphine sur Vénus ?
C'est une excellente question vous avez
certainement entendu parler de cette
détection de phosphine dans
l'atmosphère de Vénus qui est une
molécule dont sur Terre on ne connaît la
synthèse que par des organismes vivants
donc il semble très peu probable qu'elle
puisse apparaître naturellement dans
l'atmosphère de Vénus et ça suggère la
conclusion à laquelle on pourrait
arriver
puisqu'on ne connaît pas de réactions
chimiques dans l'atmosphère de Vénus qui
soit capable de générer la fascine que y
aurait des objets vivants des peut-être
des micro-bactéries en suspension
dans l'atmosphère de Vénus qui l'aurait
engendré. On n'a pas détecté ces micro-bactéries ces objets vivants tout ce
qu'on a "détecté" et je vais mettre des
guillemets autour de détecté c'est un
peu de phosphine difficile de conclure
pour l'instant tout ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'on n'a pas d'explication à l'origine
de cette fois ci le vivant serait une
possibilité mais qui n'est pas prouvé ce
que je sais aussi c'est que j'ai des
collègues à l'observatoire de Paris qui
ont regardé cette publication et qui
sont très sceptiques sur la détection en
elle-même parce qu'en fait on est à la
limite de détectabilité dont le signal, il y a beaucoup de bruit et il y a un truc
qui pourrait faire penser à une raie de la
phosphine dans un spectre très bruité
et d'après eux, les auteurs de cette
étude, ont pas mal tiré poussé le signal
dans tous les sens, en faisant tout
un travail de traitement du signal qui
est normal, on doit faire ce
traitement mais d'après eux ils ont
tiré un petit peu trop pour avoir une
petite boucle ressemble à une détection
et qui mériterait d'être confirmée quand
même donc à suivre
Que pensez vous.. Alors j'ai déjà dit. A-t-on des retours du télescope Kheops sur
de nouvelles découvertes ?
Oui mais pas moi désolé je ne suis pas
dans le projet Kheops, j'ai des
collègues qui y sont mais là je peux pas
vous donner les dernières nouvelles
alors cette question.. Exoplanète
égal vie potentielle, Fermi dit pourquoi
on les voit pas ? Réponse : les
civilisations s'autodétruisent ?
Ben c'est
une possibilité
et peut-être que c'est ce qui va nous
arriver parce que avec la dynamique
exponentielle de nos émissions de co2 on
va vers un climat qui n'est pas tenable
pour notre civilisation voire même pour
notre espèce d'ici la fin du siècle
Soyons clair parce que c'est une
dynamique exponentielle là la
température elle a pas beaucoup chauffé
depuis le début du 20e siècle
mais c'est en bonne voie et ça va faire
un climat insupportable
donc c'est une possibilité, l'autre
possibilité c'est bien sûr que les
civilisations prennent conscience des
problèmes écologiques et s'arrête avant
de détruire leur planète donc on peut
espérer que d'autres civilisations l'ont
fait et que nous on le fera aussi.
Il y à une question là-haut, allez-y je vous en prie
Parlez fort et puis court
Je voulais savoir, la technique d'interférométrie, qui a été utilisée pour imager les trou noir au sein de la Voie Lactée
Est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une technique qui pourrait être utilisée en biologie ou en détection des exoplanètes tout court
Ou non parce que c'est un domaine..
Alors je crois que vous aurez l'oreille plus fine que moi parce j'ai pas bien entendu
Je crois avoir entendu vous allez me dire si j'ai mal compris votre question vous
avez parlé de la technique
d'interférométrie qui a servi à imager un trou noir
et est-ce qu'on pourrait l'appliquer
pour détecter des exoplanètes alors les
cette technique consiste à combiner la
lumière de plusieurs télescopes pour
faire ce qu'on appelle des franges
d'interférence entre le signaux qui
vient des deux télescopes et en
analysant ces franges d'interférence on en
déduit des informations sur la source
donc sur l'image du départ avec une
résolution c'est-à-dire une
capacité d'imagés qui est équivalente à
un télescope qui ferait la taille de la
distance qui sépare les deux télescopes
donc c'est extrêmement performant
d'ailleurs ma compagne travaille là
dessus
Roxane Ligi à l'observatoire de la Côté
d'Azur et elle mesure les diamètres des
étoiles qui ont des exoplanètes
alors voilà une application de
l'interférométrie à la recherche
d'exoplanètes c'est de mesurer la taille
des étoiles pour en déduire ses
propriétés à l'étoile et donc les
propriétés de l'exoplanète qu'il abrite
également une autre possibilité
s'appelle l'interférométrie de Nulling
qui consiste à faire des franges
d'interférences de l'étoile et regarder
dans la zone noire de la bande qui est
du coup une zone verticale et dans ces
zones noires s'il ya une planète comme elle n'est pas dans la même position dans le ciel
que l'étoile elle n'est pas annulée par
les franges d'interférences et donc on
peut la voir c'est une façon d'éteindre
l'étoile
donc il ya des gens qui travaillent là
dessus notamment l'observatoire de la
Côte d'Azur et c'est une technique qui
oui effectivement permet des avancées
instrumentales pour imager des
exoplanètes on n'arrivera pas pour
autant à faire des belles images comme
celles-là
c'est juste pour essayer de les voir à
côté de leur étoile
En tous cas ça évite de décapiter des montagnes pour mettre des télescopes
Ca peut éviter de décapiter les montagnes pour mettre des télescopes
en effet si on fait que combiner deux
télescopes l'un à côté de l'autre
maintenant souvent on fait de
l'interférométrie pour faire
interférer la lumière on a besoin de
construire un tube à vide entre les deux
télescopes pour amener les photons donc
c'est pas si simple que ça si on fait de
l'interférométrie dans le domaine non
plus des longueurs d'onde optique
visible mais des longueurs d'onde
millimétriques voir radio on peut faire
des recombinaisons électronique du
signal de la lumière et donc on n'a pas
besoin de faire tous ces tubes à
vide et là effectivement c'est juste un
réseau de fibre optique, il n'y a pas besoin
de faire des grosses installations.
Alors il y à un monsieur qui demande s'il y a des
recherches sur des formes de vie qui ne
nous ressemble pas on cherche simplement
Exact le problème
c'est que on peut tout imaginer mais du
coup on sait pas comment les
caractériser donc on a fortement
tendance à chercher des formes de vie
qui nous ressemblent maintenant c'est
pas non plus idiot parce que la molécule
d'eau qui constitue 70% de notre corps
c'est une molécule qui est très commune
dans l'univers
h2o h c'est l'élément le plus abondant
et o c'est l'un des plus abondant aussi
et la molécule a de bonnes
propriétés c'est un solvant dans lequel
on peut dissoudre des nutriments et les transporter, ce qui est une
chose nécessaire aux vivants alors sur
Titan un satellite de Saturne
il fait beaucoup plus froid que sur
Terre donc l'eau est toujours gelé mais
le méthane lui est liquide et vous avez
sur Titan un cycle du méthane comme on a
un cycle de l'eau sur Terre avec des
nuages de méthane des pluies de méthane
des rivières de méthane des lacs de
méthane qui s'évapore et qui redonne des
nuages
donc certains se sont amusés à imaginer une
forme de vie ou le méthane remplacerait
l'eau mais le méthane n'a pas ses
propriétés de solvants donc c'est
beaucoup plus dur d'imaginer des formes
de vie comme ça et après une forme de
vie basée sur le méthane à la place de
l'eau le silicium à la place du carbone
pourquoi pas mais du coup comment la
détecter ? Clairement on a un biais c'est
très difficile il faut en fait, la
question de la définition de la vie
c'est quoi la vie aussi et
finalement on n'a pas une définition claire
donc on se contente de chercher quelque
chose qui nous ressemble.
Allez-y , je vous en prie monsieur
Vous avez cité le journal "La Décroissance" qui est dans l'idée de moins de bien plus de lien
Tout à fait !
Et aussi.. Je ne sais pas à quel point c'est sûr, mais en tous cas risquer la possibilité de l'effondrement
Et heureusement, il y à déjà des personnes qui changent, sur les modes de consommations, ce genre de choses.
Il y à aussi des jeunes femmes qui disent qu'elles ne veulent plus faire d'enfants
Donc il y à quand même des changements et la possibilité de croire en un espoir.
Oui, vous allez résumé ce qu'a dit monsieur
Vous avez cité le journal "La Décroissance" je le connais
c'est effectivement un journal qui
propose plein d'idées pour vivre mieux
en consommant moins
et effectivement il y a plein de gens qui
s'y mettent à l'échelle individuelle et
alors ça a l'air dérisoire à l'échelle
individuelle de changer son mode de vie
pendant que les autres polluent à côté,
on peut quand même penser que ça
entraîne, il y a une certaine dynamique et de plus en plus de gens qui font ça et
ça donne du mouvement en
faveur de ça on va finir par entraîner
le monde montrer que c'est ce que
veulent les gens et du coup les
décideurs vont prendre la décision
d'aller dans ce sens là et espérer
entraîner l'ensemble de la population il
faut agir aux deux niveaux autant au
niveau de changer le système
parce que c'est très difficile de se
mettre en opposition à un système dans
lequel on vit ont subi des pressions
pour suivre ce système
par exemple moi j'ai un smartphone je
trouve ça idiot le smartphone mais tous
mes amis m'envoient des messages sur
What's app si je n'ai pas smartphone si je le perd, maintenant j'ai pris goût
à voir Google Maps pour me déplacer dans
Rennes que je connais pas c'est génial
s'il n'y avait pas eu cette invention je
me serais débrouillé j'aurais pris un
plan à la gare voyez. C'est pour
dire, c'est difficile de s'opposer au
système donc il faut arriver à changer
le système mais on peut motiver le
changement du système en étant nous
mêmes acteurs de ce changement donc je
pense que j'ai tout à fait raison si
vous avez raison de faire cette remarque
il y a de plus en plus de gens qui vont
dans ce sens on va y arriver
Et ça rejoint une remarque sur internet
peut-être qu'il y à des extraterrestres
assez intelligent pour réguler leur
croissance
Tout à fait c'est possible et
du coup cela on les voit pas ben ça
donne l'occasion de citer le magazine
Ciel et Espace c'est le bon moment, c'est ce magazine d'astronomes
amateurs d'astronomie amateur, édité par l'association française d'astronomie
qui fait son dossier ce mois-ci sur "Les
extraterrestres sont-ils verts" on parle
des petits hommes verts en fait ils ont
peut-être vers au sens écolo et vous
retrouverez dans ce dossier de quelques
pages
Voilà, je suis cité puisque
Guillaume Langin le journaliste qui l'a
écrit a eu la gentillesse de m'interviewer,
il a interrogé d'autres personnes pour
développer un peu sur le paradoxe de
Fermi est ce ce phénomène, cette
question.
Voilà donc à suivre si vous
avez envie d'en savoir un peu plus sur
la question encore plus de questions
bon bah moi je crois que c'est à peu
près, oh pardon pardon pardon monsieur
allez-y je vous en prie.
Vous avez parlé, donc, du paradoxe de Fermi
Peut être que vous avez des idées là-dessus.. Pourquoi finalement rechercher des
civilisations extraterrestres
intelligentes
Qu'est ce que ça pourrait nous apporter
puisque, peut-être, l'espoir c'est qu'on
ne puisse pas les contacter et qu'elles
ne puissent pas à nous contacter
Pourquoi chercher des civilisations extraterrestres ?
Qu'est-ce qu'elle peuvent nous apporter ? Et est-ce vraiment utile ?
Clairement, c'est la curiosité qui nous pousse on aimerait pouvoir communiquer
avec elle l'homme a toujours voulu
explorer on a rencontré d'autres
civilisations sur terre pour commencer
on s'est enrichi de ces échanges
donc je pense que ce serait extrêmement
motivant d'arriver à communiquer avec
une civilisation extraterrestre
intelligente
maintenant si on trouve une forme de vie
sur une autre planète qui n'est pas
intelligente mais qui est quand même une
forme de vie on sera déjà super content
la communication sera forcément
difficile avec une forme de vie
développé, dite intelligente mais si
on la trouve on se dira qu'on n'est pas
tout seul et c'est quelque chose
d'énorme d'arriver à imaginer ça
maintenant faut se rappeler dans
l'histoire de la vie de la Terre que je
vous ai montré là les trois premiers
milliards d'années de l'histoire de la
vie sur terre
l'histoire la vie sur Terre n'était
pas très communicant, c'était des
algues qui faisait bloup bloup dans
l'océan c'est tout donc c'est pas
folichon folichon donc là il ya de
fortes chances que si on trouve de la
vie sur une exoplanète ça ressemble à ça
mais on sait que ça a énormément de
potentiel après
On s'arrête là ? On en reste là ? Et ben oui
merci beaucoup merci Aurélien Crida
d'être venu jusqu'à Rennes depuis
Nîmes en train, merci pour cette
conférence qui a été suivi par 1400
personnes sur le site de
l'espace des sciences sur notre chaîne
YouTube merci à vous autres de vous être
déplacés
je rappelle que voilà c'est pas toujours
facile il y a un certains d'entre vous qui
n'ont pas pu entrer ce soir dans notre
salle nous en sommes fort marri mais
nous sommes limités au point de vue
places et je vous rappelle qu'il y a aussi
une possibilité : s'abonner à l'espace des
sciences qui vous donne droit à des
séances de planétarium, aux expositions
voilà et à la réservation pour les
conférence. Mais renseignez-vous sur le
site de l'espace des sciences.
Merci à toute notre équipe régie vidéo,
régie maison des associations, régies
champ libre, à nos hôtesses et hôtes et
bonne soirée à vous tous à bientôt